hey-yah I'm Mason Ramsey and I'm here at
BuzzFeed to answer some fan questions
how did you get into yodeling I don't
know I just did it hey lady lady how did
you find out you were going to be
performing at Coachella no one told me
this that I was gonna be at Coachella
and so I was like where's Coachella and
I didn't really know so it's you know
it's like a big thing I'm the first
youngest person in country music to sing
at Coachella when did you first realize
you were famous I just woke up one day
got the call from Ellen she wanted me
and I went there and that's how I got my
my my booster she kind of kind of like
all righty let's mix and match chair
which artist would you most like to hold
operate with ought to go with Blake
Shelton on that one because he's fun
okeydoke
if you could have any superpower what
would it be well I got a great one if
there was a zombie apocalypse I would
use my ovum to kill every single one of
them lady it'd be like when blowing
trees how do you feel about all of the
remixes made from DJ suede is my best
bro so he helped me out a lot so I'm
gonna say good Thank You DJ suede what's
the weirdest thing a fan has said to you
so one day I was playing Minecraft
and that was his person on minecraft and
my cousin was playing online
my cousin asked are you a big fan of
Mason Ramsey and she's like no I think
I'll pass like haters or haters and
people who like you they helped are you
coming out with any new music soon
because famous is a Bop might be it has
very new songs my single release famous
Yoda lady who if you listen to that that
songs on my EP too that one is a teller
that's a pop like it's a wine dancing
song how did you get the idea to sing in
Walmart I just sing I'm a singer who
likes to sing so I if I find something
that I do it's just sing if you weren't
a singer what would you oh I know what I
wouldn't be I would be a basketball
player play it Duke then go to the
Golden State Warriors play with Kevin
Durant Steph Curry
draymond Green Kevin Durant Thunder I'm
sorry Thunder for everything I know I
love Katie when it was on the Thunder
but now it's time I love the Thunder
coach Billy Donovan but now it's coach
Steve Kerr what what's your favorite
song currently played on the radio these
days I would say famous but for all the
people who like famous song I'm sorry I
gotta let you down I like I like the way
I see it and I know there's a couple out
there who like the way I see it because
that's the only way I see it
thanks BuzzFeed I had fun and thank you
fans for all your questions
it'll do good bye see you next time on
Busbee
[Music]
[Music]